cada día cientos de personas arriesgan
su vida para llegar a sap orilla los
conductores colocan carteles en las
ventanas de sus autos señalando que hay
niños a bordo al tiempo que huyen de su
ciudad natal mariupol
vivimos bajo la ocupación durante dos
meses sufrimos todo el tiempo esperamos
a que nos rescataran pero no vino nadie
así que decidimos subir alguien nos
ayudó a llegar hasta aquí no había
ningún corredor humanitario ni nada nos
arriesgamos el vértice de la ciudad
portuaria de mariupol ha sido destruida
casi por completo en los combates la
mayoría de los intentos de evacuación de
los residentes han fracasado y según las
autoridades ucranianas 100.000 civiles
siguen retenidos dentro de la ciudad
y esperamos que llegue gente todos los
días pero el último convoy de autobuses
fue hace una semana esos cuatro
autobuses eran los únicos de un corredor
humanitario
hemos estado esperando por esas promesas
de la onu
el secretario general de las naciones
unidas antonio guterres aseguró que la
organización está haciendo todo lo
posible para evacuar a los ciudadanos la
ciudad está totalmente bajo control ruso
a excepción de la planta siderúrgica de
azov tal donde se estima que entre 2.000
y 3.000 soldados ucranianos resisten a
las fuerzas de moscú cientos de personas
se han refugiado en sus túneles y se
están quedando sin comida agua y
medicinas